- Please welcome Liza Koshy.
- You, you are wonderful,
what an introduction.
- Well, and actually-
- Presidents call me.
- It's true, I just watched your latest
Cup of Joe interview with Joe
Biden on your YouTube channel.
- It was a good hot, cup
of hope, it was wonderful.
- It's so amazing, your roster
of not only accomplishments,
but your diverse actionable interests.
And I think everything
you touch turns to gold.
- Stop, keep going.
- I have such a deep respect for you.
I was really excited to do
this interview with you.
I was like I-
- Wait real quick, girl,
you were describing me,
and I could not tell if you were
not being humble and describing yourself.
Ma'am, you are so versatile.
Let me get my compliments out.
You are literally a beam of light
shot down from the heaven
above to create joy.
And you do it well.
If that was too strong, I'll
just say it, I love the you.
- No.
- So yes, with the show.
- I wouldn't know how to
not come off too strong.
I spend my life like a Labrador
in heat, I'm like (pants).
- Me too, small Chihuahua for me.
- Oh, perfect, well, we can be.
(pants)
Yes.
Oh good, okay.
- We're two small dogs.
- When you like found Vine,
what was your first foray like?
What were your thoughts, feelings, goals?
I'm dying to know because
you catapulted such a large,
important, interesting career out of it.
So what was that seed in origin?
- Yeah, well, it was very deep,
very intentional, very strategic.
I basically sat down in
my car and pressed record.
That was my first time
ever creating a Vine.
The next, I upgraded to a different set.
It was a bathroom.
And that's where I started
creating, was my set was my home.
And I clearly can't shut up,
so I just created on YouTube,
and started transitioning
into creating characters
and scripts and creating
this world to play in,
and see if others would
come along for the journey.
But yeah, these different
characters I created
were different extensions of myself.
So I had my confident self.
I played the role of a confident man,
which we've seen, you
say absolutely anything.
And then I had the role
of a maternal mother,
of sorts, in my life that I
created through a character.
And then I had a younger version of me,
which is my inner child.
So creating all these
different moments for myself
to express as those versions of myself,
and then consolidate and
become the woman I am today.
That's kind of how I
created things online.
And it's been a journey.
It's been a wild one, but it's fun.
- I was so nervous and excited
because I think that when...
- What, you, me.
- Yes, because-
- Girl.
- It's true, because first of all,
I love you as a beauty junkie.
I mean, come on, you have mad technique.
- Mad technique, girl,
I'll take that, thank you.
All of these compliments
are making me schvitz, girl,
so hold on, speaking of makeup.
- Good, by the way, by
the time you leave here,
you're gonna look like you
just came out of a pool.
So where did you...
Do you just on film, try a cloud eye,
or do you practice it
first and then film it?
- You know, I appreciate
and love the beauty community so much.
You say I'm a beauty junkie.
I call myself beauty chunky.
I'm real new here, I'm the new girl.
I say chunky because sometimes
my makeup's not perfect.
And that is a reminder that
perfection will never exist.
And yeah, I'm living proof of that.
- If there's perfection,
there's imperfection.
You can't get one without the other, so.
- Yeah, perfect's an idea,
imperfect's the truth, but.
- You know what?
My daughter's school motto
is brave, not perfect.
- Okay, so I've been real brave
with my makeup looks
then, and creating those.
'Cause I have no idea what I'm doing,
but I step into it wholeheartedly.
And then throughout the
course of my videos, girl,
you see like the shine come.
'Cause like you say, beauty
starts from the inside out.
I love that you say that.
It's the way you feel.
And you always remember
how someone makes you feel,
or how even a product makes you feel.
So that personal touch,
that's why I make sure I have
that in everything that I do.
Because it makes you feel good.
It's from a human to a human.
(audience claps)
- Did I read a story about
that you put some food
frozen in your suitcase,
possibly In-N-Out Burgers?
- Yes girl, okay, so real quick,
I am from Houston, Texas, born and raised,
always represents real well, like Beyonce.
And I packed frozen
Whataburger in my suitcase.
To convince my friends in California
who don't know what taste is.
But I packed that up and I froze it.
And I tried my best, and I
brought it home in a suitcase,
and girl, that freezing did not work.
It just melted, it smelled
like a gym locker room
after a Friday Night Lights
football game, it was not good.
- By the way, you bring up
"Friday Night Lights" quite a bit.
I've read several quotes where you talk
about "Friday Night Lights".
Are you a "Friday Night Lights" fan?
- Clear eyes, full heart, can't lose.
- (screams) It's the best show.
- I lived it, so I was on the drill team.
I'm Lieutenant Liza
Koshy, at your service.
And I was on the drill dance
team in Houston, Texas.
And I had my Friday Night Lights dream.
I dated a football player.
I was one of the captains
of the drill team.
I went on that field
and did my high kicks.
- So you're a lot like
(indistinct) you're (indistinct).
That makes sense, because I was trying
to look into your dance background.
You are such a good dancer.
- Thank you, thank you.
That's where, born and
raised Houston, Texas.
So it started ballet when I was a kid.
And that's actually how
I got into makeup too,
was being underneath Friday night lights,
but also those bright stage lights,
and having to wear like
pretty much acrylic paint
on a kid like seven or eight
years old is when I started,
and the brightest, pinkish blush possible
underneath those lights.
So that's where I learned
like how to beat my face
in order to look right.
I was also one of the only
Brown girls on that stage too.
So I definitely had to find
my foundation pretty fast.
And I experimented with
my sister's makeup.
It didn't work for me, had
a lot of breakouts actually,
a lot of trips to the dermatologist.
Still owe them money to
this day, I'm still running.
But you know, that whole experience
really made me realize
what works for my skin.
It's natural, organic ingredients.
You know, what you worry about
putting on the inside of your body,
you know, natural, raw, whole
foods, is what you should be
putting on the outside of your body too.
At least for me, that's what works for me.
Those are the recipes
that work on my skin.
And so to create something
that might be the answer
to other problems that kids are having,
I wanted to create the
solution on the shelf.
If not for myself, for somebody else.
(audience claps)
- These are such bright,
beautiful messages.
- Coming from an angel shot down
from the sky above yourself, what?
- You mean the Labrador in heat? (pants)
- The Chihuahua.
- Yes, exactly!
We're two little doggies!
- I get you on that vibe, yup.
We need to walk soon.
(upbeat music)